- For the first time in nearly 30 years,
a person was killed on a film set
after being accidentally shot.
Is Alec Baldwin going to jail?
(upbeat music)
The camera crew was setting up for a shot
when Alec Baldwin put his
hand on the Colt .45 revolver
in its holster and said,
"So I guess I'm gonna take
this out, pull it out,
"and go, 'Bang.'"
(gun firing)
What followed was shock and confusion.
As Baldwin pulled the
gun out of its holster,
a lead bullet exploded from the muzzle,
hitting Director of
Photography Halyna Hutchins,
who tumbled backwards.
Director Joel Souza also hit the ground
when the bullet exited Hutchins's body
and embedded in his shoulder.
"What the F just happened?"
That was the question Baldwin
repeated over and over again.
A 911 caller alerted the dispatcher
that there was trouble on set.
- [Script Supervisor]
Bonanza Creek Ranch just had
two people accidentally shot
on a movie set by a prop gun.
We need help immediately.
Bonanza Creek Ranch. Come on.
- [Dispatcher] So, was it
loaded with a real bullet?
- [Script Supervisor] I don't,
I cannot tell you that."
- Hutchins's death sent shockwaves
through the entertainment industry,
which had just averted a crippling strike
by film industry workers.
Hollywood TV and film
crews were still reeling
from a 2014 train accident
that killed Sarah Jones
and injured eight others.
Her death, and now the
loss of Halyna Hutchins,
are raising serious questions
about workplace safety
on film and TV productions.
So today we're gonna talk
about who was responsible
for what happened on the set of "Rust."
Could there be criminal penalties?
Could Alec Baldwin face
manslaughter charges?
And what about the armorer
and assistant director
who were responsible
for checking the guns?
Now, an important
standard disclaimer here,
we don't know what happened
on the set of this film.
We don't know what actions
people took or did not take.
A lot of that will come as a result
of the criminal investigation,
which appears to be in process.
So a lot of this video
is gonna be speculative
based on hypotheticals of
what may have happened.
So, don't jump to any conclusions here.
A lot of this information
is going to change
and a lot more information
is going to come to light.
But first let's talk
about this movie itself.
"Rust" is an upcoming western
written and directed by Joel Souza.
It stars Alec Baldwin, Travis
Fimmel, and Jensen Ackles.
The plot follows a 13-year-old
boy who goes on the run
with his grandpa after the
boy is sentenced to hang
for an accidental killing.
The Los Angeles Times has the
most updated reconstruction
of what happened on the "Rust" set.
Their timeline is based on interviews
with 14 members of the crew,
official statements by
the parties involved,
and the search warrant affidavits.
The events that led up
to the shooting started
at 6:10 a.m. on Thursday
when six members of the
camera crew walked off the set
before the day's filming got started.
Their resignations came
after a week of complaints
about unsatisfactory working conditions,
including a lack of safety on set.
In the days before the camera crew quit,
Hutchins had tried to resolve
some of their complaints
by forfeiting a half day's
rental of a Technocrane,
equipment that enables
photographers to get aerial shots.
She hopes that by sacrificing
part of her budget,
the producers could spend the money
on closer lodging for the crew.
The lodging problem was so serious
that it became a running joke.
Someone ordered custom T-shirts that read,
"Error 404: Housing Not Found."
On Wednesday, the night
before the shooting,
Jonas Huerta, the digital
utility technician,
wrote an email outlining
his safety concerns:
"I also feel anxious on set.
"I've seen firsthand our
assistant director David Halls
"rush to get shots and he
skips over important protocols.
"He often rushes to shoot.
"I've had more than a few occasions
"where I've been close to
the weapons being fired
"with no regards to my hearing.
"Sometimes he rushes so quickly
"that props hasn't even had
the chance to bring earplugs
"and he rolls and the actors fire anyway."
Just 10 hours later, Hutchins
was surprised to find
the camera crew was leaving.
As she tearfully hugged
the camera operators,
Line Producer Gabrielle Pickle
told the camera operators
to pick up the pace and get off the set.
She threatened to call security on them.
That's when David Halls
interrupted the scene
to rush Hutchins away,
saying that they needed
to prepare for the day.
Baldwin's call time was 7:54 a.m.
At 8 a.m., the crew had a safety meeting.
After a few hours, they
completed the first shot.
Lunch was called.
Property master Sarah
Zachary retrieved the guns
that would be needed for
the scene from a truck
where the weapons were
stored inside a locked safe.
The ammunition was also in the truck,
but had been left unsecured
on a cart during the break.
Crew members told the
LA Times that Baldwin,
"Was pretty concerned
about safety on the set."
When Baldwin rehearsed this
shot a few days earlier,
"He wanted to know where
I would be standing
"when he drew his gun."
Apparently the camera technician told him
he'd be standing in a different
spot, and he said, "Good."
However, before the fatal shot was fired,
there was apparently a
major security breach.
David Halls told investigators
that his typical onset safety protocols
included him checking the
gun barrel for obstructions
before the armorer opens
up the hatch to the weapon
and spins the drum.
Halls told investigators that
Reed performed a safety check
with a Colt .45 in front of Halls.
Although he thought he saw
three rounds inside the gun,
he did not check them before
taking the weapon in his hand.
This is apparently a serious
breach in safety protocols,
which require more than one
person to check the gun.
Halls then ran through
Baldwin's blocking himself,
pulling the gun from the holster
three times without incident.
He did not, however, pull the trigger.
And before Baldwin was ready to film,
he wanted to do a quick rehearsal
while the director and
Hutchins lined up for the shot.
Evidently, Halls is the person
who handed the gun to Baldwin,
and early reports from the set indicated
that the Halls yelled, "Cold gun,"
before giving the weapon to Baldwin.
However, new evidence indicates
that this might not be true.
Now, Halls and Reed are pointing
the finger at each other.
Reed says that Halls
handed the gun to Baldwin,
yelling, "Cold gun."
But he claims that she was the
one who yelled, "Cold gun."
Other crew members
remember Reed being the one
who told Baldwin the
gun was actually cold,
meaning it held blanks.
However, if someone had
double checked the rounds,
they probably would have realized
that they weren't blanks.
A visual inspection would have showed
that at least one lacked
the small hole or indent
that visually differentiates
dummies from bullets.
They also would have noticed
that it didn't make the signature rattling
that proves that there's only BBs
and no gunpowder in the dummy round.
But admittedly, these are small details,
which is why productions
rely on experts in firearms
rather than performers to do the checks.
But the end result is that when Baldwin
started to rehearse his quick draw,
he pulled the trigger and
then watched helplessly
as the bullet hit Hutchins.
Several reports say
that after the shooting,
Baldwin repeatedly exclaimed
that he had never been given a hot gun,
a firearm with live rounds, on set.
But who has responsibility
for gun safety on set?
Well, as you can imagine,
the use of firearms on set is subject
to stringent safety standards.
According to the website
for the Santa Fe chapter
of the IATSE, the union for film workers,
an armorer must be on set when any weapons
or firearms are used.
"Armorers liaise with the
director of photography
"to determine which camera
angles will minimize
"any risk of injury.
"During rehearsals,
armorers coach the actors
"in the correct use of the firearms,
"explaining possible dangers."
And every armorer and prop expert
who has spoken since the accident
says that productions don't use real guns
with live rounds anymore,
except in extremely rare circumstances.
The use of live rounds would
probably need to be approved
by the insurance company ahead of time.
And the first news reports indicated
the "Rust" set used prop
guns with dummy ammo.
Sheriff Adan Mendoza
and District Attorney Mary Carmack-Altwies
have now spoken about the
case for the first time.
Although the investigation is ongoing,
the DA declared that the gun
did fire a live lead round.
The bullet was removed from
the director's shoulder.
This is a serious problem,
since you can imagine live
rounds are rarely used
on a film set.
Anonymous crew members told the media
that people were shooting
tin cans with prop guns
on the morning of the homicide,
and there's a possibility
that the prop guns were loaded
with live ammo and no one
checked the guns after lunch.
Mendoza said that the gun
was a long Colt revolver:
"It's a suspected live
round that was fired,
"but it did fire from the weapon
"and it did cause the injury.
"That would lead us to believe
that it was a live round."
Mendoza confirmed that,
"There was a complacency
towards weapons safety,"
while the DA said that
criminal charges may be filed
against the responsible parties.
Asked about the possibility
that Alec Baldwin will
face charges, the DA said,
"No one has been ruled out."
Investigators have collected
about 500 rounds of
ammunition, including blanks,
detectives recovered two boxes
of ammo, loose ammo in boxes,
as well as a, "Fanny pack with ammo,"
along with several spent casings.
Evidence will be sent to the FBI crime lab
in Quantico, Virginia for analysis.
A prop gun is not a toy.
TV and film crews typically use
specially designed blank-firing firearms.
These weapons cannot be
loaded with live ammunition.
Prop guns add authenticity
by mimicking the sound,
flash, and recoil of a real weapon.
And when a weapon uses a blank cartridge,
it can still be dangerous.
To achieve the flash sound and recoil,
blank cartridges are
filled with gunpowder.
They frequently contain something inside
to seal the powder in the case,
usually paper, wood, or
plastic, called a wad.
And if something is inside
of the prop gun barrel,
it will be expelled at nearly
the same velocity as a bullet.
So if a blank is
discharged at close range,
the wad can penetrate the human body.
And this is what happened when
after Brandon Lee was killed
on the set of 1994 film "The Crow"
when there was a dummy
round stuck in the barrel.
The dummy round that was
used in another scene
should have been removed
before filming a closeup
involving the weapon.
However, a .44 caliber
Smith and Wesson revolver
had been hand-loaded by someone
who wasn't a firearms expert.
The person removed the propelling powder,
but unknowingly left the
live primer in place.
This caused the bullet to
be separated from the casing
without enough energy for
it to exit the barrel.
The gun wasn't checked before
it was used to film a closeup,
and during the scene actor
Michael Massee pointed the gun
at Lee, and when he pulled the trigger,
the dummy was blown out
of the barrel killing Lee.
And the cartridges may also
result in hot exploding gas
to mimic a muzzle blast.
The gas can also serious
injuries if fired at close range.
For example, in 1984, actor
Jon-Erik Hexum was filming
the seventh episode of
the CBS series "Cover Up."
Hexum was filming a scene where
his character loaded bullets
into a .44 Magnum,
so he was given a
functioning gun and blanks.
When Hexum was frustrated
by a filming delay,
he started playing with the gun.
Hexum had removed all but one blank.
He put the revolver to his temple,
pulled the trigger as if
playing Russian Roulette.
And although the wadding
did not penetrate his skull,
the force of the blast
created by the hot gas
cracked his skull and Hexum
died from a brain hemorrhage.
And perhaps by now you've
seen the similarities
between all three of these incidents.
They all involve revolvers
rather than semi-automatic pistols,
because the requirements
for an onscreen revolver
are different than other pistols.
Now it's my understanding
that on a western film set
like this, film crews
do use real revolvers,
but they use several
different kinds of ammunition.
The first is a blank
that contains a cartridge with gunpowder.
It will shoot a flame out
when you shoot the gun,
but it doesn't contain an actual bullet.
The casing is crimps where
the bullet would otherwise go.
But since in a revolver
the bullets are exposed to the camera,
you need at least one other kind of round.
That would be a dummy round
where it does contain the actual bullet,
the round lead thing, but it
doesn't contain any gunpowder.
And so when you depress the
hammer, the bullet doesn't fire
because there's nothing to go off.
So at least with respect to
the one of the main criticisms
I've seen, why weren't
they just all blanks,
blanks wouldn't look right on film.
But since everyone knows how
dangerous prop guns can be,
how could this happen?
Should Baldwin have
checked the gun himself?
Well, given how complicated
it can be to film guns,
it's not as simple as
discharging live rounds,
it's imperative that firearms
experts check these weapons.
It's also crucial for everyone on set
to observe safety protocols.
For example, in real life,
you're never supposed to
point a gun at a person.
But typically on the set of a film,
actors point the gun at
the camera all the time.
But everyone in the line of fire
would be wearing goggles and face masks.
They also stand behind a Perspex screen.
Hutchins and Souza were
apparently checking camera angles
by looking at the monitor
when they were struck
during the process.
So this is a lot of background,
but it's necessary to determine
whether anyone faces
criminal or civil liability
as a result of what happened.
So let's talk about the
liability of the cast and crew,
and let's start with actor Alec Baldwin.
When the shooting made headlines,
Baldwin's political opponents
immediately shared their thoughts.
And of course, it's natural
to point the finger at Baldwin
because he's the one that
physically pulled the trigger
of the gun in this case.
But there's a difference
between an accidental shooting
on a movie set and an intentional killing.
New Mexico criminal law defines murder as
the killing of one human being by another
without lawful justification or excuse.
And we've talked about
the mental states required
for murder in the first degree,
which usually requires
malice aforethought,
which means did the defendant
plan to commit murder
without cause or provocation?
Manslaughter, on the other
hand, is defined as the,
"Unlawful killing of a
human being without malice."
Because manslaughter does not involve
the mental state of malice,
it's considered less serious than murder.
Malice aforethought is
a criminal term of art
that I'm not going to go
into the nuances here,
but it doesn't mean anger necessarily.
I'm going to assume that
Baldwin did not intend
to hurt anyone here, so that
means murder is off the table.
Now, New Mexico manslaughter
cases are classified
as either involuntary or voluntary.
Voluntary manslaughter involves a killing
that occurs during, "A sudden quarrel
"or in the heat of passion."
As far as we know, that
doesn't apply to anyone
on the "Rust" film set, including Baldwin.
The crime of involuntary
manslaughter involves a killing
that occurs in the commission
of some other unlawful act
or a felony crime.
Involuntary manslaughter also
involves a killing that occurs
while the defendant is
engaging in a lawful
but dangerous act without exercising
due caution and circumspection.
And an example of an
involuntary manslaughter
might be a fatal traffic
accident caused by a driver
who was texting while driving.
And to prove involuntary manslaughter,
prosecutors must show three things.
First, that someone was killed
as a result of an act of the defendant;
second, that the act
was inherently dangerous
or done recklessly;
and third, that the
defendant should have known
the act threatened the lives of others.
And prosecutors don't need
to prove intent in New Mexico
for involuntary manslaughter
because it can be committed recklessly
or through an inherently dangerous act.
And the primary defense to
involuntary manslaughter
is that it was just an accident.
A defendant can show that
they didn't act irresponsibly
or didn't know that their
action could have resulted
in another person's death.
So the question is, did
Baldwin act recklessly
or commit an inherently dangerous act?
Did he violate standard safety procedures
by pointing the gun directly at people?
Well, the early reports
suggest that Baldwin
didn't just pick up the gun and
start pointing it at people.
According to the crew members who spoke
to the Los Angeles Times,
"Baldwin removed the gun from its holster
"once without incident,
"but the second time he did so,
"ammunition flew towards the
trio around the monitor."
This suggests there was
something wrong with the weapon,
but shouldn't Baldwin have
checked the gun himself?
Wouldn't anyone handling a
firearm check the gun themselves?
Well, Mike Tristano, an armorer
who worked with Alec Baldwin
in the 1998 movie "Thick as Thieves,"
said that, "He was great to
work with and was very safe.
"I was surprised to hear it was him.
"He was always on the mark
and very professional.
"He's not stupid."
Industry insiders seem to
indicate that it's totally normal
for an actor to rely on
the rest of the film crew
to properly handle the weapons,
especially when some of the crew
have explicitly told the actor
that the gun is safe to be
used in the circumstances.
And that probably makes sense
to delegate this responsibility.
Actors aren't necessarily
gonna know all the ins and outs
of all the different firearms,
especially when different
kinds of ammunition are used
in the same scene.
And of course, if actors did
have to recheck every firearm
that they were given,
that could create even more uncertainty
and allow things to go
wrong in different ways
if they didn't reload
the weapon correctly.
So, this sort of delegation,
in my mind at least,
as an industry standard
seems like it makes sense.
So under the scenario as we know it,
for Baldwin to be charged,
he'd probably have to know
that there was a live round
in the gun ahead of time.
A weapons expert said
once the weapon is loaded
it's impossible to tell what's inside.
And Tristano said that
it was not Baldwin's job
to check the gun:
"Someone professional on set
"should have been handling that gun.
"This makes no sense."
So then the only question is
whether Baldwin was negligent
or reckless in handling the weapon,
and it doesn't seem that we
have any facts to indicate that,
for example, he was
playing around with the gun
or doing things that
someone told him not to do,
which is probably what would be necessary.
So although Baldwin probably won't face
any criminal charges,
the likelihood that he is going to be sued
as a producer of the movie
is probably pretty high.
But it doesn't mean that
no one from the "Rust" film
will face criminal liability.
Is it possible that Baldwin
or others could be charged
with another crime like
negligent use of a deadly weapon?
Well, negligent use of a deadly weapon
consists of, one, discharging
the firearm into any building
or vehicle or so as to
knowingly endanger a person
or his property;
two, carrying a firearm
while under the influence
of an intoxicant or narcotic;
three, endangering the safety of another
by handling or using a
firearm or other deadly weapon
in a negligent manner;
or four, discharging a firearm
within 150 yards of a
dwelling or building.
Now, Subsection 3 may
be in play in this case.
An early report said that
the New Mexico police
were trying to determine whether the gun
would be considered, "A deadly weapon."
And based on what we know about prop guns
and firing dummy rounds,
and the fact that they may
have actually been using
real guns with fake ammunition,
one would think the answer
in this case could be yes.
And some members of the
"Rust" crew have put the blame
on the assistant director.
A script assistant who called 911 said--
- [Script Supervisor] This mother(beep).
Did you see him get up in
my face and yell at me?
He's supposed to check the guns.
He's responsible for what happened.
- And there were also prior complaints
about unsafe working
conditions on the "Rust" set.
On October 16th, the union
that represents people
who work on theater and film
crews nearly went on strike
over bad working conditions.
The IATSE crew cited low wages,
long hours, and unsafe sets.
The "Rust" crew said
that the set was unsafe,
echoing many of the
concerns that IATSE had
when it threatened to strike.
And just hours before the shooting,
seven camera crew
members working on "Rust"
walked off the set to protest
low pay and long hours.
Crew members had been told
that the producers would pay
for them to stay in
hotel rooms in Santa Fe.
But when they arrived on set,
they were told that they would
be staying in Albuquerque.
That's a one hour drive from the film set.
That means that crew would
have to drive one hour to work,
then be on set for 12 to 13 hours,
and then drive for another
hour back to Albuquerque.
They were allegedly only
getting five hours of sleep.
The crew also said their
paychecks had been delayed.
And three crew members told the LA Times
that they were concerned with gun safety
because there had already been
two accidental prop gun discharges:
"There were no safety meetings.
"There was no assurance that
it wouldn't happen again.
"All they wanted to do
was rush, rush, rush."
One anonymous person said
that he was so alarmed
by the prop gun misfires,
that he sent a text message to
the unit production manager.
The LA Times reviewed a text message
sent before the shooting that read,
"We've now had three
accidental discharges.
"This is super unsafe."
Deadline cites an unnamed source
who said a gun had gone off
in a cabin while someone was holding it.
"A gun had two misfires in a closed cabin.
"They just fired loud pops.
"A person was just
holding it in their hands
"and it went off."
An anonymous crew member tweeted
that the crew had sent a
message about gun safety
shortly before walking off the set.
Past and present crew
members have also spoken out
against Assistant Director David Halls.
In 2019, Halls was the assistant director
for the movie "Freedom's Path."
In that movie, a gun discharged,
which injured a crew member.
The injured man was a boom operator
who suffered inner ear injuries.
Halls was fired and the
armorer was replaced.
The "Freedom's Path" production company
confirmed the incident:
"Halls was removed from
the set immediately
"after the prop gun discharged.
"Production did not resume
filming until Dave was off site."
Now, however, the
anonymous crew members said
that there was no armorer
on "Freedom's Path,"
that Halls let a background actor
take control of the prop gun,
that there was no safety meeting,
and that several people asked Halls
if the weapon had been cleared
of ammunition and gunpowder,
but Halls didn't say.
The "Freedom's Path" producers denied
that part of the story.
And now we've heard
about several incidents
involving gun safety and David Halls.
These incidents could clearly be relevant
towards civil liability to the producers
who continued to hire Halls
and might have had notice
of his past behavior.
Now, producers from three productions
involving Assistant
Director Halls have issued
carefully worded statements
about what happened on their sets.
That's because they
might have legal exposure
for injuries that happened
on their projects too.
The cause of action against
producers would be negligence.
The New Mexico Wrongful Death
Act allows monetary recovery
for a death that occurs as a
result of someone's negligence.
The statute provides that
parties seeking recovery
can pursue an action
if legal recourse would
have been available
for a personal injury.
And this is something that
people get wrong all the time.
When someone passes away,
the legal cause of action
just doesn't go away.
The estate can sue on behalf
of the deceased person.
Having actual knowledge
of lax safety protocols
and actual knowledge of prior misfires
is the kind of thing that takes negligence
to actual recklessness,
and might go from civil
liability to criminal liability.
Firearms experts told Variety
that actors are given fake guns
until it's time to shoot the scene.
When it's time for action, the
actor is handed the real gun:
"It is understood that when
the firearm is handed to him,
"it is in proper working order.
"And that is a responsibility
of the armorer or prop master,
"whoever is in control
of the firearms on set."
If there were prior incidents
of accidental weapons'
discharge on the "Rust" set
and the assistant director knew about them
but didn't correct them
or insist on greater safety protocols,
it's possible that he could be charged
with involuntary manslaughter.
Prosecutors would need to
prove that the staff committed
a lawful but dangerous act,
such as handling a prop gun,
and did not act with due caution.
Now remember, to be convicted
in the state of New Mexico,
the prosecutor needs only
to prove that someone was,
"Endangering the safety
of others by handling
"or using a firearm or other deadly weapon
"in a negligent manner."
And that takes us to the
person that's responsible
for maintaining the weapons
on the film set: the armorer.
The armorer on "Rust" was the daughter
of a legendary Hollywood armorer.
And last month the
armorer told the podcast
"Voices of the West" that
she had just completed
her first film, a western
starring Nicolas Cage.
Her job on "Rust" was just
her second as lead armorer.
She said that it's standard
to assume that no one on set,
from the actors to the crew,
had ever handled a weapon before.
And that person explained
that her philosophy
was that films should always use blanks.
However, she said--
- [Hannah] Some people really
don't want you to dummy it
for some reason, just out
of their own, I don't know,
how they want to feel
comfortable, I guess.
- She could have been
referring to the producers,
directors, or other prop masters.
We don't know if anyone decided
to use live rounds on set.
The armorer said, quote--
- [Hannah] I think loading blanks
was like the scariest thing to me,
because I was like, "Oh, I
don't know anything about it."
But, you know, he taught me that,
and eventually by the time I
was like trying to figure out
how to make a specific blank
go when you want it to,
rather than it hitting
like the empty cylinders
and everything, figured
that out on my own.
- [Host] Explain that process.
- [Hannah] So normally,
if you, like, you know,
you open the loading gate,
you put the bullet in,
you have to put it right
around to right before...
You have to bring that bullet, that blank,
all the way around to
right before the cylinder,
so then that way the next time
someone pulls back the hammer
and shoots it, it'll go off.
Yeah, and you have to, like,
look at the front of it
and determine which one is the blank
if it's dummied up, you know?
That's how I tell, at least.
- The podcaster asked if
the rest of the cylinder
is generally filled with dummy wads,
and the armorer said that usually it was.
In a video of actor Jensen
Ackles discussed the gun training
that he received for the film.
Ackles talked about
gun safety on the movie
during a convention for fans
of the TV show "Supernatural."
Ackles said--
- They had me pick my gun.
They're like, "All right,
what gun would you like?"
And I was like, "I don't know."
And the armorer was like,
"Do you have gun experience?"
(audience laughing)
- Like, what's a gun?
- And I was like, "A little."
And she's like, "Okay, well,
this is how you load it.
(audience laughing)
"This is how we check it
and make sure it's safe."
I'm like, "Okay."
She's like, "Okay, I'm gonna
put some blanks in there
"and I want you to just go over
"and fire off a couple of
rounds towards the hill."
And I was like, "Okay."
So I put the belt on, I put the gun there,
and I walked out, and she's
like, "Just make sure that you,
"you know, you pull the
hammer all the way back
"and you aim at your target."
And I was like, "Okay, I got it."
And then I go (firing).
(audience laughing)
- This statement might be relevant
to the police investigation,
as well as the investigation
by the state agency
which investigates workplace accidents.
He said the gun was loaded with blanks
and the armorer told the podcaster
that that was her strong preference.
This video might also be highly relevant
to the amount of training or lack thereof
that the actors and staff received
when they were working on this film.
There were also reports
that the crew had concerns
that Hannah Gutierrez-Reed
didn't have the necessary expertise.
Unit production manager Katherine Walters
sent a Slack message on October 8th.
It said, "Apparently props and
armor require handholding."
They claimed that there were other
accidental discharges on set.
First, Baldwin's stunt
double had accidentally
fired a blank after being
told that his gun was cold.
Reed denies that she told the stuntman
that the gun was cold.
She claims that she told the man
that the gun was hot with blanks.
Second, "A young woman
from the props department
"actually shot herself in the foot."
That round was a blank.
And following the press
conference by police,
Hannah Gutierrez-Reed
released her first statement
about the shooting.
According to her lawyers,
the producers hired her for two roles:
armorer and prop assistant.
She said being the prop
assistant made it difficult
for her to do her job as armorer.
She said that she requested more time
for training the actors,
and this was denied.
She also said that both she
and the prop master Sarah
Zachary had complete control
over the guns.
Reed told investigators that
on the day of the shooting,
during lunch the firearms were secured
in a safe with a combination
on a white prop truck that only
a few people had access to.
But the ammunition was
left on an unsecured cart
and wasn't in a separate
locked compartment.
Reed was adamant that there
was no live ammo on set.
She said she, "Never witnessed
anyone shoot live rounds
"with these guns, nor
would she permit that."
After lunch, Reed said that
Zachary got the firearms
from the safe.
During filming, she,
"Gave the gun to Baldwin
"a couple of times,
"as well as to First Assistant
Director David Halls."
Reed denied that any of the weapons were,
"Unaccounted for or being
shot by crew members."
According to Reed, she
locked up the set's guns
at night and at lunch.
Serge Svetnoy was a crew member on "Rust."
He wrote a Facebook post
blaming Hutchins's death on,
"Negligence and unprofessionalism."
Although he didn't name the armorer,
Svetnoy clearly referred to her:
"I'm sure that we had the professionals
"in every department, but one,
"the department that was
responsible for the weapons.
"There's no way that a 24-year-old woman
"can be a professional with armory.
"Professionals are the people
who have spent years on sets,
"people who know this job from A to Z.
"These are the people who
have the safety on set
"at the level of reflexes.
"They do not need to be told
to put the sandbag on a tripod,
"fix the ladder on stage, or
fence off the explosion site.
"They have it in their blood.
"I'm calling out to the producers."
Svetnoy said producers cut corners
by hiring unqualified
people to save money.
And the producers obviously
pushed back on that claim.
Because it's not just the
people that are on set
that might face civil
or criminal liability
as a result of what happened.
It's possible that the
producers of the movie
might face vicarious
liability for the negligence
that may or may not have happened on set
or potentially negligently hiring people
who weren't capable of
delivering the safety
that was required.
And not surprisingly, the
use of firearms on set
involves extra layers of
disclosure and planning.
Producers usually have
to submit their plans
for using firearms on set for
review by insurance officials
or else it's hard to get
a bond for the production.
For liability purposes,
Baldwin was probably entitled
to rely on the assistant
director yelling, "Cold gun,"
but new details about
the shooting indicate
that we can't totally
rule out homicide charges
against the armorer
and assistant director.
Prosecutors would still need to show
that the responsible
person had a deprived mind,
and in practice, this occurs when a person
intentionally engages in
outrageous, reckless conduct
with a total indifference
to the value of human life.
However, mere negligence or
recklessness isn't enough.
The prosecutor must prove that
the person knew their conduct
was greatly dangerous
to the lives of others.
An example would be a person shooting
into a crowd of people.
So, if live ammunition
was deliberately loaded
into the firearm that
was handed to Baldwin
by a person who knew the gun
would be pointed at others,
then that could be a murder case.
But more likely what we're looking at here
is a case of manslaughter,
whether voluntary or involuntary,
because it looks like someone just engaged
in manifest negligence
or extreme recklessness.
So, detectives will also
take into consideration
whether there really were
two accidental discharges
before the shooting,
because that speaks to
very, very lax protocols.
And if that turns out to be true,
that there were many
accidental discharges,
which should never happen,
and the assistant director or
the armorer knew about this
because they were responsible for it,
then they might have some
serious criminal liability,
probably just not a homicide.
And Brandon Lee's family settled a lawsuit
against producers of "The Crow."
The death of camera assistant Sarah Jones
in a train accident also
resulted in a lawsuit,
in addition to new protocols
for filming on railroad tracks.
I'm sure all of this will
come out in an investigation,
but plaintiffs will want to
know who knew what and when.
Were people aware that
the crew had walked out,
that they had complained
about safety issues?
Did people know about the
other accidental discharges,
if those actually happened?
Did people talk to anyone?
Did they make any changes in protocol?
There've been thousands, if not
tens of thousands of movies,
that have used firearms since
the Brandon Lee incident
in the '90s, and none of them, until now,
had resulted in someone dying.
Now, there's still a
ton that we don't know
about this incident, but
it's entirely possible
that someone is going to jail over this.
And someone is certainly
going to pay a lot of money.
But this video isn't over.
There is an extended discussion
of the Baldwin incident
over on Nebula, thanks to
today's sponsor Curiosity Stream.
And I'm thrilled to announce
my first Nebula original,
"Bad Law Words Good."
It's a long form
documentary where I explore
the most common legal
and linguistic comments
that people throw around in everyday life,
though they do it extremely incorrectly.
So strap in, 'cause it's
gonna get really pedantic.
It's a hilarious romp through
legal misunderstandings,
logical fallacies, and
"Law and Order" parodies.
And it's only available on Nebula,
which you can get for free
with Curiosity Stream,
because Nebula is a place
where we can experiment
with content and do things that
we couldn't put on YouTube.
And we're thrilled to be
partnering with Curiosity Stream
because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries
and long-form educational
content on the internet.
They even have an entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries and crime.
So if you like my videos,
you will love the stuff
on Curiosity Stream.
And we worked out a deal
where if you sign up
for Curiosity Stream with
the link in the description,
you'll also get a Nebula
subscription for free.
And to be clear, that Nebula
subscription is not a trial.
It's free for as long as you're a member
of Curiosity Stream.
And right now, Curiosity
Stream is offering 26% off
their annual plans.
That's less than $15 for the entire year
for both Curiosity Stream and Nebula.
So if you click on the link below,
you'll get Curiosity Stream
and Nebula for 26% off,
or you can go to
curiositystream.com/LegalEagle.
It's a great way to support this channel
and educational content directly.
And it's the only way
to see my documentary
"Bad Law Words Good."
So just click on the link
that's on screen right now.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're there,
click on this playlist
with all of my other Real Law reviews.
So click on this video
or I'll see you in court.